In the Atlantic Ocean, about a thousand miles
west of Africa, is Null Island. It's a busy
place: Thousands of people live there, millions
of photos have been taken there, and occasionally,
people teleport in for just a moment or two
before disappearing to somewhere else.
Or at least, that's what it looks like to
a computer. Because if you actually set sail
for Null Island, you’d find nothing but
deep blue ocean and a lonely weather buoy.
Or boo-ey, if you’re American. There is
one special thing you might notice: it’s
at exactly zero degrees longitude and zero
degrees latitude -- and that’s the key to
why computers think this particular patch
of ocean is a busy place.
Any big database, whether it's storing information
about people, photos, or cats, needs to know
the difference between “nothing”, like
zero, and nothing, as in, there’s no data,
it’s a mystery. That idea of “no data”
is called “NULL”. So here we know that
Ser Pounce has black fur, and Mr Sniffywinkles
has brown fur, but we don’t know about Schrödinger.
NULL doesn’t mean “no colour” or “no
fur at all”. It literally means "there is
no data here, we don’t know what color her
fur is".
This isn’t just a cat-related problem. If
your phone doesn’t know where you are, it
might tag a photo you take with latitude NULL
and longitude NULL, or it might tell an app
that your location is NULL, NULL. No problem
so far. But badly written apps can read that
as co-ordinates “zero, zero”: they’ve
mistaken nothing for “nothing”. So they’ll
think that you are on Null Island -- at least
until your phone works out where you really
are. More seriously, in a 2012 US election,
many voters in Wisconsin lived in places that
the Census Bureau didn’t have co-ordinates
for. So a new, automatic system said they
lived on Null Island… which is definitely
not in any Wisconsin election district. If
the mistake hadn’t been caught in time,
they might have had problems voting.
You can also get problems when you try to
put the actual word "null" into a database,
like you might try to do if you’re one of
the 300,000+ people with “Null” as your
last name. It only takes a small programming
error -- mistaking “Null” for NULL -- and
suddenly, the computer thinks you don’t
exist, or at least you can't register an account
with your favorite kitty-litter-cleanup-service.
All this is a reminder that our world is complicated,
and it’s not always as easy as you might
think to map our messy reality into a computer
system. So the next time you see a photo tagged
way out in the Atlantic Ocean, you’ll know
what’s happened. Unless it really is a photo
of that one, lonely weather buoy. Boo-ey.
thanks to Tom Scott of the amazing youtube
channel, Tom Scott, for helping write and
brilliant other videos on his channel, Tom
Scott.